[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so now we're about to do this
very traditional tea ceremony I can't
wait to see you in a little kimono cutie
little compute nod didn't work I was
trying to mix Qt and come on I didn't
work
oh no he wants it come on now cutie all
right first layer on oh this is pretty
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's very appropriate since you know
we're here for spit matcha if we get to
do a traditional style tea ceremony with
matcha we get to learn the actual
process through a traditional way of and
it's also so cute seeing everybody
dressed up in like an actual kimono
do I make a handsome Japanese man yep go
camping helmet looks so pretty
that goes upset that he's wearing his
kimono thingy
[Music]
my job who knows good we're good coffee
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
the tea farm we're finally gonna learn
about matcha and we are gonna go to a
different hotel cuz we're done staying
in this hotel how'd you like Kyoto good
yeah like dude talk about your summary
class yesterday
oh yeah those
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're checking out the tea farms here in
OG and it's really cool because we're
learning a lot about matcha and the way
it's made and the process and like just
learning all about the importance of the
process of making matcha and we're
learning the difference between green
tea and matcha too so it's pretty
interesting really enjoying this trip
I'm so happy we're able to come with the
family they are harvesting right now and
that's this is green tea harvesting so
over there they are using a machine so
it's not hand-picked so it's not the
highest quality of green tea this is
like day to day drinking type of green
tea and then that stuff that's shaded
that is matcha so the reason why they
shade these tea leaves and they call it
matcha is because when it's under this
shade it creates more chlorophyll and
when it does that that's when it has a
stronger taste and it's just better
quality stuff so it's pretty cool the
main reason why Kacie and I came to this
trip what's obviously you know to spend
time and bond and everything but it's
also to create some content for like
marketing content for sip it's kind of
cool because this is the first time that
we're working together as a team like
this because I'm actually directing the
shoot I'm telling him what shots to get
and I'm telling Jun Dan Anna and Jeremy
they are like the core founders so we're
calling them we're calling them the core
four and so like I'm pretty much
directing them and telling them like
alright guys walk up ok now stop and
like pretend oh you're having a great
time without this stuff it's kind of
funny because I've never been in in like
a director's hat and I'm not fully like
you know obviously Casey's still running
the show but it's kind of cool to help
him and really call out the shots and
tell them like hey Casey this looks
really great right here it's really
amazing so it's been a really fun
experience who I'm gonna breath [ __ ]
these are the rolling hills
it's really pretty we have the rest of
the group they went ahead
so Isaac's over there with them yeah
we're just really enjoying tea farm in
Japan
[Music]
like I've been so obsessed with Isaac
it's so freaking cute hi papa would not
be ever I know it's not fun
Isaac you should know all right we're in
our second hotel we are now in Nagoya so
the cool thing about our hotel room here
we have a cute little kitchenette like
the sink and that cute little fridge and
then if you open this door it's the
bathroom with the shower with in here
it's like what what's behind this thing
here we have a Chinese man eating some
bread oh but look check out the views
look at this view pretty cool view it's
actually raining today but I thought it
was kind of funny that there are window
cleaners in the rain but then Casey made
a good point saying well they are
scrubbing up the dirt I'm like yeah but
it's still kind of funny it's like
washing your car in the rain so this
hotel I actually booked us two rooms
because it doesn't online that each room
is only for two people and since there's
three of us I was like all you know what
as you could have his own room for the
second hotel so he's super excited about
having his own hotel room for the very
first time he's such a big kid now but
we had to wait a little bit for the room
to be ready because they're still
cleaning it up and getting it ready but
this is an onsen so we actually have
like a what's a bit like a public
bathhouse kind of thing or not public
but like you know with the residents
that are staying here and so I'm really
looking forward to take a nice relaxing
bath especially with all the girls
cuz I don't think it's co-ed and I think
it's like one of those nude nude
how's this type of places and so I asked
Isaac I'm like dude are you down and get
naked would you say yeah sure you don't
care okay for you to be naked in front
of all of our friends yeah actually I'm
just gonna be like that you're gonna
cover yourself yep what about the fact
that you're you might catch a glance at
someone else walking what if your trip
then I'm really looking forward to is
gonna be relaxed yeah you love Beth do
you should I think you were a Japanese
man in your previous life yeah because
you love baths you love ramen you love
oh now it changed to [ __ ] yea Vietnamese
man I used to read Japanese
but yeah Isaac I know how you feel about
being naked and stuff because I
someplace with with me because my
brother and my dad are also coming to
this hotel we're just gonna oh yeah I
have your verse I bathed with them you
never seen them naked never know because
we're not Japanese and my dad
particularly my dad hates like spas and
stuff like that so he's probably not
gonna do it then you might not do that
yeah so me and my brother but like yeah
my brother and I don't take baths
together yourself maybe when you were
kids we were kids yes that's one thing
but like now it's like it's been it's
been 20 years since we've seen each
other's bodies you know weird and what
has changed since then
so oh yeah see Isaac what exactly are
you excited about in terms of having
your own room your own hotel room
honestly I didn't think that you would
be excited because you are the type of
kid that's very attached to us and every
time we want to leave you alone for it
like even a second
you're really skin
all the time you're like oh I don't
wanna be by myself remember when we took
the cruise and you didn't want to stay
in the room by yourself so what changed
now I don't really care you don't care
to be alone anymore
look good as the hotel room I sleep well
so was the cruise you still didn't feel
safe
he's just like your kind of older now
you're able to handle yourself now yeah
you handle bad guys so someone comes and
Rob's you in the middle of 1915 handling
oh yeah got the shoehorn
oh and yesterday he read he learned how
to use a samurai sword all right Oh what
supposed to be like haha you mean the
guy said you could make any noise you
want like Isaac's noise yeah old man
that's arcane instead of a sword
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's actually really big we all fit here
which is very surprising for a Japanese
standards
[Music]
humph I do my job
[Applause]
chicken wings oh wow that's the pepper I
like how it's like a beacon all right so
we're back in the room now after dinner
I think what are you wearing so you have
to wear these robes yeah I look like
Jesus you look like Jesus you look like
hisses yeah so are you excited you're
about to see some naked people oh you're
gonna go a Joe daddy who else
Jeremy yeah is that it what it's Casey's
changing right over there
well yeah you're about to see daddy
naked no no you know what are you gonna
do you're gonna try to keep your eyes to
the ceiling yep
well I can't see far away so I'm lucky
oh yeah you're not taking your glasses
nice then I have my room key over here
oh don't lose that don't lose it oh did
you bring your towel from your room oh
no yeah you got to go get that I can't
are you wearing underwear no oh you
didn't at the Blue Lagoon yeah but I
looked away Oh smart but this time you
can't avoid it
yeah but no this is this is different
because you guys are gonna be chilling
in the hot tub and there's no way he
could get away from the new did you see
other people make it at the Blue Lagoon
oh but luckily no no keep your head up
like with your hands behind your back
yeah so while they go to the onsen
I'm going to knock out tomorrow morning
we have to wake up at five in the
morning this morning we woke up at five
in the morning to get over here from
Kyoto ah but tomorrow morning it's
another very early day and it's already
8:30 already like it's late it's still
really really early but I'm just so
exhausted earlier today I took a nap
and I woke up from that nap feeling like
I was a zombie I was so dead I was so
tired I just couldn't like I couldn't be
alive
so during dinner I was like I'm not
gonna go to the content I'm just gonna
go save that for tomorrow
and I'm gonna knock out right now next
day now and we are at the actual farm
where we sources I'm watchin from and
right now we're checking out the highest
quality form of matcha it looks like
this see there's like fully shaded
leaves and then so they're saying that
this is how you know it's hand-picked
cuz it's all like wild form and then
over here is all nice and neatly picked
so this is with the actual machine so
this is not hand-picked and in Kasey's
working on our SIPP video
[Music]
you're actually picking it right now so
you could see it's all hand picked
they're getting the best of the best
leaves right now is the highest quality
feet all right now we're under one of
these shades but there are so many
spiders and they're huge but they're
saying that the spiders don't bite but
I'm like look how pretty it looks like
pre-harvest oh yeah you see all the
shades they're saying that when the
shade is this high of a high school
because they're able to retrieve all the
temperature with the KC over their head
all itchy like something's crawling in
it like which one yeah we can leave how
do you know which which actually when we
see here yes from here it looks this is
old yeah so from here we just
thank you mmm believed something really
good I don't know what I'm looking for
tastes like salad all right so now we're
checking out the actual factory hairnet
so this is a very sterile area
[Music]
so after they dry it they have to
separate the stem in the vein from the
leaves so it's not that bitter and this
is what's left over and this is the part
that they grind up and that's the matcha
part before he crushes it
this is the traditional way of
separating this Stanford
oh these are the stone mills are
grinding up all those leaves we just saw
that are dried ok the traditional kind
of grinders and at the very end is it
matcha that's what we get that one turns
to that one turns to that one you can
get it at your home layer you want one
destroy the army take the one that
you've touched that's wet already
the toy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
good well this is like the most legitly
japanese restaurant of it seen so far
[Music]
we're all getting we're all getting
rejected by babies like high school all
over again oh one thing I'm not a big
fan of in Japan is sitting like this I
[Music]
realized at the age of 30 I realized
that that really really stiff hips it's
quite people every 10 minutes I like to
get up stretch my legs around which I
feel like it's very not proper here in
Japan to do that but I don't know I
don't like seeing like this and it makes
us all look like children I think like
lo me there's a mosquito in your face
I'm like nunchucks there now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think of the yeah you know
where your what are you chicken
import you're eating eel you know where
you're eating your down to eat that
what's it taste like
but it's good salmon it tastes like
salmon to you mmm like the ones I may
come home I see
high five I guess that's that yeah all
right so I'm really proud of Isaac for
this meal because doesn't normally like
eating fish even though there was
chicken s an option where's the other
stuff that's not yeah I think he heard
most of us saying no this place is known
for he'll try to heal heal heal heal
heal sorry actually order didn't you
what just keep it with my my story yes
[Music]
[Music]